What’s up guys, my name is Colin
McNeil for theScore esports.
Last Valentine’s Day, we gave you a video
called “The Top 10 hottest League of Legends
Players,” and you loved it.
Yeah.
So this year, we’re giving more of what
you want, with the Top 10 hottest
players in CS:GO.
Now hold on, before you start writing an essay
in the comments section promising to unsubscribe, hear me out.
We evaluated these players based on their highlight potential, recent success,
relevancy to the game and, yeah, their good
looks too.
So now that the criteria's out of the way, here is the Top 10 hottest guys in CS:GO.
Peanut brain?
I don’t think so.
Nobody is underestimating the tactical prowess
of tarik after Cloud9’s incredible Major
win in Boston.
And you know what, I have it on good authority
that smart is sexy.
That’s why we’ve picked him to start off
this entirely scientific...
...Top 10 list.
(Casting)
Ah yes, the Bosnian beast.
NiKo’s frags are always hot, but since joining
FaZe Clan we feel like his style has really
improved as well.
Damn, this dude has some swag.
And it’s worth noting that NiKo has obviously
been hitting the gym lately.
We’d be doing him a real disservice if we didn’t
give him props for the hard work he’s
been putting in.
Now let’s cut the shirtless selfies and get
to the good shit, those sexy NiKo frags.
(Casting)
You know, I won’t lie, I did not have jdm
on this list originally.
But some of the women in the office just wouldn’t
stand for it.
The bandana-wearing, chair reclining American
AWPer had been an integral part of Team Liquid
since the summer of 2016.
That is until his recent departure in February
of this year.
He’s like the all-American boy next door…
if the boy next door could hit flick shots
like this.
(Casting)
And hey, if that didn’t convince you, take a
look at this bizarre video from ESG Myknonos,
with jdm coming out of the ocean, Daniel Craig
style.
The first and only Frenchman on our list,
shox can do it all.
He can AWP with the best of them, outduel
just about anyone on rifles, and clutch like
you wouldn’t believe.
(Casting)
And when it comes to matters of the heart, I like
to imagine he’s equally well-rounded.
Everybody loves a renaissance man, am I right?
And hey, that suave haircut and pretty solid
jawline don’t hurt either.
They say success is the best aphrodisiac.
Well, in our next player’s case, he’s
got plenty of that.
…success, I mean.
Arguably the best player in the world, Coldzera
also sports one hell of a manly moustache
that practically exudes testosterone.
We’re talking Tom Selleck levels of manliness
here.
And just like NiKo, Cold has clearly been putting
in work at the gym.
These days he’s looking like a lean, mean
fragging machine.
And if you do manage to resist the Brazilian’s
animal magnitude, just take a look at these
highlights, OK.
(Casting)
Coming in at number five is another player
that the female contingent here in the office
just couldn’t leave off the list.
The clean cut Danish superstar himself, dev1ce.
Recently bouncing back from an injury that
kept him out of competitive Counter-Strike
for months, dev1ce is back as the primary
AWPer for Danish powerhouse Astralis and we
are glad to see it.
I have to admit, I’m starting to see the
appeal.
But whether he's your type or not, you just
can’t argue with plays like this.
(Casting)
Ah, Sean Gares.
Analyst, in-game leader and not a bad fragger
himself.
Is there anything this guy can’t do?
(Casting)
Between leading Misfits to some pretty impressive
results, to appearing on the ELEAGUE analyst
desk, we’ve been seeing a lot Mr. Gares
recently, and that, combined with his good
looks, has landed him the number four spot
on our list.
They say confidence is the key to attraction
and Sean has plenty to be confident about.
“You are not my friend, you are my brother,
my friend.”
Do I really need to explain why Pasha Biceps
is on this list?
This dude is swole.
The guy looks like he could curl a
bus-and-a-half.
Plus he has some absolutely adorable children
and I know the ladies love a family man.
Awwwww.
Oh yeah, and I guess he’s a pretty good
Counter-Strike player as well…
(Casting)
I’m just going to come out and say it, one
taps are sexy.
Although he hasn’t been in top form recently,
ScreaM is still the undisputed king of single
shot and tight spray AK kills.
Uh, sorry, wrong clip.
(Casting)
I could say more about ScreaM’s dashing
good looks, piercing eyes and well groomed
facial hair, but hey, I think the highlights
speak for themselves.
This is it people, our number one hottest
CS:GO player, and who else could it possibly
be, but the X-God himself?
Dosia a living legend not just in Counter-Strike,
but in the Russian dating scene as well.
His exploites in love are almost as well
known as his accomplishments in esports.
A 1.6 player who successfully made the transition
to Global Offensive, the Russian playboy is
a Major champion, and a major heartbreaker.
Now before you get too hot under the collar,
I do need to inform you that, as of September
2017, Dosia is a happily married man.
(Casting)
Ok, that was our list and you made it this far. So go ahead, flame me. But I don't know about you, I feel the energy in the air.
It’s like Cupid just one tapped me with
his Deagle of love.